Aaleeyah Pringle Alim:
"You have to get your
wisdom teeth removed."
Amin Elsaeed: OK, big myth here.
Big, big, big myth.
[Pringle Alim laughs]
"Charcoal toothpaste is better
than regular toothpaste."
Pringle Alim: No. No, no, no.
"There's no such thing
as brushing too much."
Elsaeed: Try to brush for
at least two minutes, right?
Sing "Twinkle, Twinkle, Little Star."
Pringle Alim: What? I
feel like that's so short.
Elsaeed: No, like, sing the whole verse.
Hey, everyone, my name
is Dr. Amin Elsaeed.
I'm a dentist working out
of the Chicagoland area.
And my name is Dr. Aaleeyah
Pringle Alim, also a dentist.
And we are here to
debunk some dental myths.
Elsaeed: Myth No. 1:
"Sugar causes cavities."
Pringle Alim: Oh, my gosh.
Sugar actually is not
the cause of cavities.
In your mouth, you have
active normal bacteria,
and when sugar is fed to that bacteria,
the bacteria produces acid,
and it creates cavities on teeth.
Elsaeed: So it's the fuel
for the bacteria to cause the cavities.
Pringle Alim: Myth two:
"Electric toothbrushes
are better than regular toothbrushes."
Elsaeed: The most important thing
is that you are actually brushing, right?
So having that mechanical
movement against your teeth,
whether it be an electric toothbrush,
a regular toothbrush,
that's the most important
thing to prevent plaque
from sitting on the surfaces of our teeth.
So if you have a regular toothbrush,
you can still do a good
job of brushing at home.
Myth No. 3: "White teeth
are always healthy."
Pringle Alim: White teeth
really just have to do
with how your enamel
appears on the surface.
So, your tooth actually has three layers.
It has the inside core, which is the pulp.
It has that middle layer,
which is yellow in color.
And then it has enamel,
which shows up whiter.
It's like the armor of your tooth.
So, genetically speaking,
if you don't have the type of teeth
that will appear whiter after whitening,
you'll have to go maybe veneers or crowns
to get a whiter, whiter, whiter smile.
Elsaeed: It's very possible to have,
you know, cavities, bone loss,
periodontal disease, even
with pearly white teeth.
Pringle Alim: All right, myth No. 4:
"There's no such thing
as brushing too much."
Elsaeed: Anytime you want to
take plaque off your teeth,
we're all for it.
But then it comes to how
hard are you brushing, right?
Some people go in there,
and it's like a chain saw.
They're just [makes chain-saw noise].
And what ends up happening
is when you break down
that enamel by so much, so much
hard and vigorous brushing,
you end up getting sensitivity.
So people are like,
"Oh, I drink something,
and my teeth hurt."
Pringle Alim: Go and you
look at your toothbrush,
and if the bristles are
flared out like this,
you're doing it too hard.
Elsaeed: Myth No. 5:
"Drinking with a straw
is better for your teeth."
Pringle Alim: This is kind of
true, but also kind of false.
So, drinking through a straw
is theoretically better for your teeth
if done the right way.
So, if you drink through the straw
and the liquid literally
just passes from the straw
maybe to your tongue to your throat
and you swallow, then that's OK.
But the problem comes with
when people drink through the straw
and they still kind of swish
it around in their mouths,
that kind of defeats the purpose
of drinking through the straw.
It's damaging your teeth
the longer that that
liquid sits on your teeth.
So, drink it fast if you can,
drink it through a straw
the right way if you can,
and always, always, always
follow it up with water.
If you can follow up your
acidic drinks with water,
you can help your body get
your pH back down to neutral
or back up to neutral quicker.
Myth six:
"Brushing harder makes
your teeth cleaner."
Elsaeed: OK, brushing harder
does not make your teeth cleaner.
What makes your teeth cleaner
is effective brushing.
If you're brushing the right way, right?
If I take my toothbrush
and I'm jamming it in there
with 600 pounds of force against my teeth,
I'm causing a lot of damage.
So it's not about the strength;
it's more about the motion.
Pringle Alim: Angle your
toothbrush a little bit
so that the bristles are
actually angled into the gums,
and you move back and forth.
Think about brushing two
to three teeth at a time,
instead of large, big strokes.
Elsaeed: Myth No. 7. This is a good one.
"Charcoal toothpaste is better
than regular toothpaste."
Pringle Alim: There is
no research that suggests
that charcoal toothpaste is better
than your normal fluoride
toothpaste. Zero.
What people are kind of attracted to
about charcoal toothpaste
is that it promotes
the idea that it will whiten your teeth.
People went as far as
to taking raw charcoal,
like, just kind of charcoal powder,
and brushing their teeth with that
in hopes that they were going to, like,
I don't know, unlock a
secret whitened-tooth door.
No. No, no, no.
So, what can end up happening is,
if you use charcoal too much,
you can end up wearing away your enamel,
which will then make your
teeth appear more yellow,
the opposite of what you want.
Myth 8: "You have to get
your wisdom teeth removed."
Elsaeed: OK, big myth here.
Big, big, big myth, I know.
[Pringle Alim laughs]
Listen, man, let me tell
you, let me tell you,
you do not have to get
your wisdom teeth removed.
If there is a specific reason,
like it's causing you pain,
the tooth now has a giant cavity,
the tooth is impacted or now pushing up
against the tooth in front of it
and now it's just causing a whole drama
inside your mouth, right?
For a lot of people, that
can be a very valid reason
to have those teeth removed.
And another reason that these teeth
should be removed sometimes is
getting to those third
molars by ourselves at home
and cleaning them, or these wisdom teeth,
can be very, very difficult.
Pringle Alim: If they're
in line with the others
and if they're completely fine,
yeah, you treat it like any other tooth.
Elsaeed: Myth No. 9:
"You should brush right after every meal."
Pringle Alim: After you eat,
your mouth becomes more acidic.
So, it just naturally does. It
doesn't matter what you eat.
And if you take something
mechanical, like bristles,
and rub it up against your
enamel in an acidic environment,
you can more easily wear down your enamel,
and you're doing more harm than good.
So what you wanna do, you
wanna wait a little bit.
You wanna wait at least 30 minutes
until your mouth gets
more basic, more neutral,
and then go in and brush.
Elsaeed: I always tell
my patients, you know,
if you eat and then you have
food stuck in your teeth,
you're literally throwing a free buffet
to bacteria that didn't
pay to get in there.
Pringle Alim: Myth 10:
"Teeth grinding is not a serious problem."
Elsaeed: A lot of people
don't know that they grind their teeth.
A lot of it is you grind at night
subconsciously when you're asleep.
You don't even recognize
that you're doing it.
So, what teeth grinding does, No. 1,
it can start wearing away at
the surfaces of your teeth.
So, if you wear away the protective layer,
now you are at a much higher risk
of having way more sensitive teeth.
When you used to drink a
cold glass of water before
and didn't feel anything,
now there's a chance,
if you drink that cold glass
of water without enamel,
that you may have experiences
with some sensitivity.
Another reason that grinding
is a serious problem
is that it can have effects on our jaw.
Pringle Alim: If you're like
me and you're a grinder,
you definitely need to get a mouth guard.
Teeth grinding is definitely on the rise.
Elsaeed: Myth No. 11: "Gum bleeding means
you should stop flossing."
Pringle Alim: Do not stop
flossing because your gums bleed.
You gotta just push through it.
Gum bleeding basically means
that there has been so much
inflammation around your tooth
and so much potential foodstuff
that's kind of stuck there,
when you disturb it with the floss,
your gums get angry, and
then they start to bleed.
Elsaeed: Flossing is never going to have
a negative effect on your oral cavity.
Pringle Alim: Coming in
hot with myth No. 12:
"Aligners will straighten your teeth."
Elsaeed: OK, this is a
very loaded question.
What is the stability of their teeth?
How long are they going
to keep these teeth?
Are their gums healthy?
Is the bone healthy?
By jumping into aligners
without having that
very crucial knowledge,
there's a chance that when you're trying
to straighten these teeth,
you could lose these teeth.
Pringle Alim: A good
rule of thumb for me is,
if they don't take X-rays and
they wanna move your teeth,
you probably should not let them do that.
Elsaeed: Myth lucky No. 13:
"Toothaches always mean cavities."
Pringle Alim: When you
think about a cavity,
you think of a small hole in your tooth
that's gonna get filled with something.
You don't know what, the dentist does it,
and then it's fixed.
But a toothache can be
kind of an indicator
for something way more serious.
So, it could possibly be an indication
for bone loss.
When you bite down and
you're having a lot of pain,
it could be because the
bone around your tooth
has started to resorb,
started to disappear.
It can be an indication of
a fracture in your tooth.
Myth 14: "Chewing gum
is just as good as brushing."
Elsaeed: Chewing gum is nowhere near
as good as brushing, right?
So, chewing gum definitely has
some positive properties, OK?
No. 1, if you're gonna chew gum,
you wanna try to chew sugar-free gum.
Or, if you wanna look for
gum that has xylitol in it,
which is a great sugar option in your gum,
what that's gonna do is
it's going to promote saliva production.
But, for as great as
chewing sugar-free gum is,
it will never take away
or be a substitute for brushing, right?
You have to go in there
with the mechanical work,
toothbrush, whether electric, manual,
and get those surfaces of those teeth
clean and free of plaque.
Pringle Alim: Your oral health
is a part of your overall health.
So, it's not something separate.
Like, you can't just take your mouth out
and put it someplace.
You have to treat it like
it's a part of your body.
And so daily maintenance is crucial.
Elsaeed: A lot of people have,
you know, dental anxiety.
Like, it's normal. It's
a lot to think about.
There are so many factors
that people think about
before deciding to go to a dentist.
Sometimes going to the
dentist to just talk
can really make a difference.
Pringle Alim: If you want more information
about oral health and just best practices,
you can always check out Ada.org,
and they have tons of resources.
Just type it into the search bar,
and something will pop
up that can help you.